la petite mila était en parfaite santé
puis soudainement a dit c'est moi elle
est paralysée
du coup jusqu'au bout des orteils
elle est atteinte de la milliers d
transverses une rare maladie
neurologique pour marcher un peu pour
marcher à quatre pattes et ramper par
terre manger elle même si c'est du style
depuis que le malheur s'est abattu sur
leur fille mélanie joannette et keven
gulab se battent pour obtenir des
services de réadaptation qui permettront
peut-être à millas de marcher un jour en
novembre
la fillette a pu passer deux semaines
dans un centre spécialisé de baltimore
un séjour défrayés par la régie de
l'assurance maladie qui lui a fait faire
un grand pas en avant
la dernière thérapie elle est en train
de marcher elle même dans la marche est
jusqu'à faisait peau avec 0 voyant les
progrès la famille a présenté une
demande pour retourner à baltimore
c'était en janvier dernier le dossier
est toujours à l'étude
entre temps on les a dirigés vers le
centre de réadaptation marie enfant de
l'hôpital sainte justine
lors d'une rencontre en mai
l'établissement s'est engagé à prendre
mille en charge en septembre
mais ce n'est toujours pas fait par
courriel le centre nous a répondu qu'il
est prévu d'accueillir l'enfant dans un
très court délai c'est dans l'enfance et
futurs de mon enfant qui n'épargne
qu'est ce qui se passe présentement le
donc qu'est-ce qui est pour fait
présentement à votre année tout le reste
de ses vielles pis
tout ce que le système public offre à
millas présentement ces trois heures de
réadaptation par semaine des services
insuffisant aux yeux de ses parents qui
ont décidé de lui payer des thérapies au
privé trois heures par jour trois jours
par semaine
la facture hebdomadaire et 2000 dollars
la famille n'a pas le choix c'est une
course contre la montre
milla doit suivre des thérapies
intensive pour faire des progrès plus on
laisse passer du temps sans stimulation
sans activité ben je dirais qu'on réduit
les chances de allez pouvoir chercher
quelque chose allait pouvoir chercher
plus de fonctions chez l'enfant le cas
2001 n'est pas unique
depuis un aviron la docteure grain jean
accueille de plus en plus d'un fin dans
sa clinique
habituellement les enfants sont pas se
sont suivies puis là on en rentre
vraiment beaucoup ces derniers temps
beaucoup qui ont congé ou avec la
pandémie on ne sait pas trop ce qui se
passe ils ont plus accès aux soins
le printemps dernier pendant la pandémie
milla a perdu momentanément la
réadaptation qui lui était offerte par
le régime public
sa mère craint que la même chose se
reproduise pendant la deuxième vague
le québec est mis sur 'pause' mon enfer
accompagné de mettre son handicap sur
pause bonjour juste que ma fille est là
les services qu'elle a droit
la famille se sent abandonné par le
système
elle espère que son cri du coeur sera
entendue ici olivier bâche un réseau
canada saint-constant
[Musique]
-